John: Good morning, Hank, so here's how the
Paper Towns tour went.
I said goodbye to my beloved vacation hammock
and also my beloved family, and then drove
across Michigan to Lansing, blasting The Mountain
Goats the whole way.
Stopped only once on the drive, peemergency,
then I was in the airport, and then on a plane,
and then I was driving through New York City
watching the sun set behind the skyline.
My hotel room was fancy, but I couldn't sleep,
so I woke up groggy, ironed clothes, brushed
teeth, got dressed, and met up with my friend
and publicist Elyse Marshall, and then headed
over to the YouTube Space to meet Nat.
Nat: John!
John: We collabed with The Gregory Brothers,
and then did an interview with The Young Turks,
where one of the interviewers was wearing
a pink shirt with a green dragon breathing
orange fire, like Young Margo does in Paper
Towns, and my life felt weird.
Paper Towns is about the challenge of understanding
that other people are as complex as you are,
which is very hard for anyone, but especially
for anyone living inside this weird publicity
machine, because it does ultimately sort of
commodify everyone it touches, and I was thinking
about that as I saw two-dimensional images
of my friends, or possibly my characters,
plastered all over New York City.
Anyway, got some lunch for my publisher, Julie
Strauss-Gabel, who has on her wall the first
map ever made containing Agloe, NY, and we
talked about how much she liked the movie,
and then I had to go to Burbury to get a suit
for next week's premiere and on the way, I
confessed to Elyse that I was a little bit
tired, and she pointed out that technically,
the tour had not yet begun.
Flew to Indianapolis and drove through my
hometown before experiencing the unspeakable
luxury of sleeping in my own bed.
The next morning, I discovered a trove of
clean pants, which never happens even at the
fanciest hotels.
Then I met up with Halston Sage and Nat and
we did interviews and interviews and interviews,
before heading over to the Murat theater.
I signed books for a while in a suit that
I only now realize was quite wrinkly, and
then there were more interviews and more interviews
and then, once I was good and sweaty, I got
my picture taken with Nat and Halston.
Then the show started.
Nat and his brother Alex played some songs
together, and I love both those guys so much,
and I love watching them play music together,
because it reminds me of my own relationship
with my brother, except for the part about
how Hank refuses to let me into his band,
simply because I cannot sing or play any instruments.
Then I went out on stage with our great host,
Akilah Hughes, and I felt this immense wave
of energy and then the mayor of Indianapolis
came out and declared July 14th, 2015 to be
John Green Day, which, you know, very weird,
and afterwards, I got to meet Anthony and
Jack from the Indianapolis Colts, and then
everyone was feeling pretty good and we flew
to Columbus, and I got to have a drink with
Akilah, and then I went to bed.
I'm not sure why I videotaped every bed on
tour.
I think I was just excited about the prospect
of sleeping.
Woke up a couple hours later just a smidge
tired, but the car taking me to interviews
had ice cold Coke Zero in it, so that was
nice.
Met up with Cara and Cara tried to adopt this
mongoose-like thing named Sherman, and then
we did a TV interview where Cara reluctantly
beatboxed, and I was told that the anchors
really liked my book, No Fault in These Stars.
Then we did some more interviews and then
back at the hotel, I signed some books, and
then went to the theater, where we got to
sign for fans for a while, and then there
were interviews and interviews and interviews
until I was good and sweaty, which meant it
was time to be photographed.
The crowd in Columbus was amazing and asked
great questions and I kept thinking about
how long ago my college days in Ohio felt,
but before I could get properly nostalgic,
we were yanked away to the airport on a flight
to Dallas.
The next morning, I got dressed, brushed my
teeth, and found Nat and Halston atop a balcony.
God, I love those guys.
Then I got my makeup done, and then interviews
and interviews and interviews.
Went to my room to sign some more books and
then headed over to the theater where Dallas
was hot.
Now, I didn't have a thermometer with me,
but I think it was in the neighborhood of
15.7 million degrees Kelvin.
Fortunately, because she is a good friend,
Elyse was kind enough not to videotape me
getting photographed while my face melted
from the heat, but then, after just two changes
of shirts, I was able to meet our hosts, Gabby
and Allison from Just Between Us, and then
listened to Saint Motel, and finally meet
the amazing crowd in Dallas who were just
awesome, and then suddenly, it was over, and
we were on a plane to LA.
Hank, the Paper Towns movie is out in most
of the world now, and I'm so grateful to everyone
who has watched it and shared their responses
via nerdfighteria's #wallofcow.
It's been a long and difficult two months
for me.
I've missed my family a lot and I'm so glad
to be home with them now, but what an adventure
that week was, and like the best adventures,
it brought me closer to people I love, so
thanks to all of them, and to everyone who
made the movie.
Hank, thank YOU for a great VidCon, I am now
going to sleep until Friday, I will see you
then.